>> Recorded Message:
From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC:
>> Please welcome Professor
Edward O. Wilson.
[ Applause ]
>> Edward O. Wilson: Thank you.
[ Background Noise ]
.
>> Thank you so much [inaudible].
And thank you all for coming.
This has been a wonderful
day for me.
I'm sure it has been for you, if
you could stand the Washington heat.
[ Laughter ]
>> I would, I think, most
appropriately address the writing,
and meaning, and the goals,
that I had been writing a novel
for the first time in my life.
After the first book I wrote,
after 43 years of non-fiction,
more than 25 books, and
after 42 years at Harvard,
teaching undergraduates in science,
its evolutionary [inaudible]
biology, I decided to venture
across the great boundary
of the creative arts --
into the creative arts,
and write a novel.
I think it's a fairly rare
thing for a scientist,
particularly a lifelong
scientist, to make that journey,
to take that dare,
to undergo that risk.
Because more than one critic,
most of them have been friendly,
a critic has said, I risked a
lot by doing that, and now I want
to tell you why I did it.
But first before I do, I'll tell
you a broad outline of the --
give you a broad outline
of that book, Anthill,
published March of this year.
The story is really basically a
coming of age story of a young boy
in Alabama, south Alabama, I guess,
that part is autobiographical.
And I should add right now that one
of my reasons for writing it was,
after being away from
Alabama for 60 years
where I grew up; I
wanted to go home.
I can't pick up and
leave Harvard right away,
so I take frequent visits there,
and I decided to write and film,
that's one of the motivations
for writing it.
And I have just finished a history
of Mobile in collaboration with one
of America's great photographers,
Alex Harris [assumed spelling].
We will bring that out next
year in which I celebrate,
and also present very frank
pictures in the history of Mobile
from Desoto [assumed
spelling] to the Oil Spill.
I've enjoyed writing that,
and that brought me back home.
But one of the main reasons that
I undertook to write this book was
with Harper Lee in mind, and I
incidentally recently was able
to visit Harper in her home in
Monroeville, not Nell Harper Lee,
she does not see many visitors.
But I managed to get in there.
We had a wonderful talk.
I had heard my -- just 50
years ago, she published,
To Kill a Mockingbird, and
it had an enormous impact,
in part because it's an
extraordinarily good book...
[ Laughter ]
>> ...and an extraordinarily
good movie was made of it.
But also it came at the cusp
of the Civil Rights Movement.
And it brought, in novelistic form,
to vivid clarity what
the difficulties were
that faced the South,
and its deep divisions.
Now [inaudible] coming out of that.
And now we have entered a new crisis
of which southerners
are only vaguely aware.
And that crisis is the reckless
destruction of their environment,
of many of their expendable,
nonexpendable,
non-replaceable resources to be
sure, including not least the water;
but also the precious
natural environments
that they have inherited
which include the species
for species first where meter,
the richest botanical environment
in numbers of species of any
place on the northern hemisphere.
And I'll be not many of
you know what that is.
It's the picture plant logs that
are sprinkled throughout the South,
with as many as 70 species of
plants all crowded together
in one square meter, beating
anything in a tropical rain forest.
But the South has so
much else in it:
the great long leaf pine
savannah that once covered 60%
of the [inaudible] of the South,
rich from one end of the Carolina's
to the Texas in beauty and in
variety of species, almost all cut
down but now [inaudible].
So our young man growing up in
southern Alabama discovers one
of the remaining old growth patches
of old long leaf pine savannah;
and because he's a lonely kid,
and he loves to roam in the woods,
and because he comes in contact
quite early with a mentor,
a professor in ecology coming
up from Florida State who's
studying this patch scientifically,
he becomes deeply bonded
to that land.
And then as he matures, to
the idea of doing something
to save this particular tract,
and then other parts of the South
so rapidly disappearing
before a thoughtless onslaught
of unplanned development.
And so he does.
And that's the major
part of the book.
It unfolds as our young Raphael
Semmes Cody [assumed spelling],
his mother named him after
Admiral Raphael Semmes,
the great naval hero
of the Civil War.
She does that partly because
she's a social climber,
or at least she's trying to
get back at the highest levels
in Mobile society, which
includes the Mobile Semmes family,
and she's married below her station,
as a head strong young woman
and now she realizes
that she's not --
doesn't belong anymore
exactly where she grew up,
and she's trying to
work her way back in.
That's another -- that's a sub plot.
But any rate, young
Cody finds the way.
He has to deal with the developers
in a novel fashion, and in dealing
with them, he had to go
through law school first.
And he finds a solution to
[inaudible] beyond the juggernaut
of development and combine goals of
conservationists and of developers
in a way to create a win-win
situation, not a complete victory.
He also has to deal with a
radical right evangelical cult.
It is now we get into
the messy part of the --
the brutal part of the novel,
and I won't go into that.
I'll leave that for those
of you interested to find
out how it happens,
and how it's resolved,
in the course of this book.
He has to study the treasure
tract that he has become familiar
with in more detail for
his college honors work.
And then he's introduced
to the anthills.
These are one of the many
species of ants in this tract
that have never been studied,
and so we stepped out to do it --
and some might add are not just
runny little specks running
around at your feet, but
they make up a two thirds
of the biomass of all the insects.
If you take the insects, all the
insects of a region, of a plot,
and weigh them, two
thirds of that --
in other words this is an ant's
world that we're living in,
and it's been an ant's
world for 150 billion years.
They own the earth.
Ants are among the little things
that rule the world, so --
and they also have the most
complex social behavior outside
of human beings.
So with little or young
Raphael Semmes Cody,
I take you into the
world of the ants,
and for the first time
this full quarter
of the book show you what
ants really are doing,
how they are organized, how
they are communicating, and --
it's like studying
society on another planet.
And you get the first realistic
view of these ants as they display
to one another in tournaments,
run colony against colony,
like military squadrons or
parades passing one another
to demonstrate their
strength when they go to war.
It's all out in one,
light's out the other.
They come in epic dimension when
you get down with them in cycles.
Civilization after civilization
speeded up to turn over two,
three or five years, and I hope
you like -- find that interesting.
But now we really come to
this matter of a red flag
to my fellow southerners, namely now
is the time to save what we have.
I hope this is a message that
can be seen as global too,
because in the current
environmental movement,
we find success beginning
-- we are turning green;
it is a pastel green globally.
But most of it is focused, and this
is true of political life on --
a cynical environment on -- the
depletion of natural resources,
on evolution, on climate change.
And so we know all those things,
we do now, and we worry about them.
But we have the neglected
disproportionately the living
environment, and the massive
destruction going on of ecosystems,
of species, many of them
millions of years old.
Each one exquisitely
adapted to its environment.
We're wiping them out without even
in many cases knowing what they are.
So I propose Wilson's Law
modestly, Wilson's Law,
and this has been mentioned in the
New York Times; and I don't want
to mention this in
the presence of one
of the forces of the
Washington Post.
But I would say that since it's been
mentioned in the New York Times,
Wilson's Law has, then
it must be true.
[ Laughter ]
>> Well anyway, Wilson's Law says:
If you save the living environment,
our ecosystems, the best of life,
you will automatically save
the [inaudible] environment.
Because you can't save the living
environment unless you take those
measures that make the physical
environment sustainable.
But if you save only the
physical environment,
and you ignore the living, then
you ultimately will lose them both.
So this is the message I take
to my fellow southerners.
I'm very active incidentally
in their conservation movements
down there, and I go and am
gradually reasserting myself,
and I'm using every method
I can to sell the message.
And I'm using the Billy Sunday
[assumed spelling] method: lectures,
books, [inaudible], letters,
so on, and now the novel.
Because ladies and gentleman,
people respect nonfiction,
but they read novels.
[ Laughter ]
>> So this is the Billy
Sunday method.
[ Laughter ]
>> Do everything.
Do whatever you can,
give a little bit.
And I chose Billy Sunday because
I've had a record of Billy Sunday
in the 1920's giving one
of his great sermons,
and I'm going to give it to you in
his words, in his accent right now.
[ In a thick southern accent ]
>> Oh I hate him.
I hate him so much,
I'm going to fight it
until I can't move my arms no more;
and when I can't move my arms no
more, then I'm going to bit him.
And when all my teeth are
gone, I'm going to gum him.
[ Laughter ]
[In normal tone of voice]
>> So that is what
I have been doing.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
>> And that is why I dared
cross from the safe havens
of fact based non-fiction into
the wild and wooly wilderness
of the creative arts,
and that novel.
And I'd now love to take
some questions or comments.
Yes?
>> Yes. Hello.
I almost feel like I need to
apologize for this question
because it's of a highly
personal nature.
But I feel a real need to ask it,
because I have the opportunity
to have your presence.
When you have someone like Steven
Hawking, who, after a lifetime
of exploring the field of
astrophysics, seems to have decided
that the idea of the existence of
God is a fiction, not a non-fiction.
I was wondering, after a lifetime
in exploring the field of biology,
what are your ideas on that issue?
>> Edward O. Wilson: I'm a scientist
who tries to base personal beliefs
on fact, and on defensible theory.
I think without any credit is one
way or the other about his opinion,
Mr. Hawkins has stepped
outside the boundary
and the clear responsibility
of a well-known scientist.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> Ginger: Dr. Wilson,
my name is Ginger.
And hello from your friends
at Triple A-S by the way.
>> Edward O. Wilson: From where?
>> Ginger: From Triple A-S.
>> Edward O. Wilson: Oh.
>> Ginger: Good to see you here.
This is wonderful.
You talked about all of your efforts
to help save the physical
environment in the South,
and I was just curious how
somebody could get involved
in whatever you're
doing if they wanted to.
Is there an official
organization or...?
>> Edward O. Wilson: Yeah.
That requires a rather lengthy
answer but I -- let me just say --
pick your -- the geographic area
you'd like to get involved in,
and get directly involved
in any one of them directly;
and that would be one of the great
global conservation organizations
of which there are approximately
four that I would recommend,
but will not because
of the possibility
of [inaudible] comparison.
But then of course there
are also national ones,
there are regional ones,
and there are action groups
within each community which
are focusing directly,
and with direct action on
particular environmental problems:
saving a last tract of some kind
of precious woodland, a lake,
or helping to protect
a species that's right
on the brink, and so on.
There's [inaudible]
opportunities, and I wish you well.
We need you.
[ Inaudible audience talking ]
>> Edward O. Wilson: I'm -- Oh.
I'm sorry.
Yeah. I didn't realize
there were two.
Yes.
>> My favorite book by you is,
Biophilia and I was really struck
when I read the book, about the
deep connection that you talked
about between the human race and
nature, our great love for nature,
and our deep connections to it.
And because I'm a teacher, I
wonder what you would say about how
that should impact education,
about teaching young people?
>> Edward O. Wilson: I think that
the idea -- you mentioned the word,
Biophilia and that's now
solidly routed in science.
It's become a major study in
areas of psychology and biology.
There's also a basophilic
architecture movement and --
so I think that would
be an excellent --
if I were teaching at
say, the secondary level,
I would consider using the idea
of basophilic, and what it means
to the human mind and human
history; I'd combine that with hands
on work -- especially
in the environment
where you can actually go out
and make actual discoveries.
And that would be how I would --
that's how I personally would
like to talk to young people,
and to get them interested in
science as well as the environment.
Sir.
>> I've enjoyed reading your
writings for quite awhile.
On the question of conservation,
and a lot of other things,
I've noticed that there's a lot of
discussion out there about trying
to do things on a grand scale,
climate change, a lot of things
like that with the
fairly large, essentially,
takings of natural lands through
things like cities, suburbia, etc,
I'm wondering -- I'd be interested
in your opinions on how much all
of us can actually do
in our own little areas,
like in our own lots then, and what
the sum total of that could end
up being, compared to, for
example, a major national thing
where it's unlikely a lot
of this legislation will
actually come to pass.
But for example, planting native
species instead of non-native lawns,
a wide variety of things like that.
>> Edward O. Wilson: Sir we know
with increasing precision what needs
to be done to save the environment
and we know what big steps can be,
and what little steps can be.
And we further know that
there's nothing more powerful
than people becoming
the boots on the ground
and actually changing the
policy at different levels,
but including the levels
where they are the most,
can be the most effective.
And as that proceeds
[sound skips] the totality
of our common effort [sound skips]
huge amount will be achieved.
But, in addition, we will
be developing an electorate
that puts the pressure upward
into our political leaders
to create the policy of
legislation and the executive action
that makes the big changes possible.
We're close to the end.
[ Applause ]
>> Can I take one more question?
Sorry about that.
>> Dr. Wilson, I've been reading
your books for quite a time.
Your book that you co-authored
of the ant I think is one
of the high points of
publishing in the past 30 years.
But it was more the question of,
are you and Catherine [sound skips]
who came to the sciences the way you
did, which is through just the love
of the natural world and
then working your way
up into the formal science.
I have one friend who's a
professor, a biology teacher,
and he came the same
way as a farm boy.
He sees less and less of that.
[inaudible].
>> Edward O. Wilson: Well that's
-- unfortunately we are --
our children are growing
up farther and farther away
from the direct content
that imprints upon children.
The [inaudible] and the great deep
of pleasures of having involvement
in the natural environment.
Yet still quite a few do, and they
are there in large numbers wishing,
if the positions were open, that
science and teaching and technology,
and I think they will be
opening, they really will come in,
talented young people, with that
kind of passion in large numbers.
I'm going to quit at this point.
I'm have to say that I have to
run away, because I'm caught
in a very tight flight schedule.
So I'm going to run out of here,
but I appreciate very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Recorded Message: This
has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.Gov.